[Music]
breaking news former soviet president
mikhail gorbachev has died the
complicated legacy of the leader who
stopped the cold war without bloodshed
also on this tuesday intensifying pleas
to help pakistan the repercussions of
unprecedented rainfall the pakistani
people are facing a monsoon on steroids
resulting from climate change as
scientists warn about the consequences
of zombie ice the water emergency in
mississippi's capital we can no longer
flush the toilets the warning to a
quarter million people
plus sobering research how a small
amount of alcohol can affect your body
and what some doctors are calling for
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight bara nasser
good evening we begin tonight with
breaking news the last leader of the
soviet union mikhail gorbachev has died
at the age of 91. he was a towering
figure as the reforms he started brought
about the end of the cold war and the
fall of the iron curtain and eventually
the dissolution of a nation he ruled
he was a hero to many in the west but he
leaves behind a complicated and
polarizing legacy in russia and across
the former soviet union russian
president vladimir putin has unraveled
much of what gorbachev did and stood for
eric sorenson reports
he was the architect of glasnost and
perestroika the opening and the
restructuring of the soviet union
in doing so mikhail gorbachev brought an
end to the cold war and helped usher in
modern europe
as a young communist a turning point for
gorbachev came on a visit to canada he
was soviet agriculture minister when he
visited the home of his canadian
counterpart eugene whalen it was here
that gorbachev and then soviet
ambassador to canada alexander yakovlev
began serious discussions to reform the
soviet union
he spoke of it years later
yes indeed i
saw in canada that people can live a
better life a freer life in the early
1980s three aging soviet leaders
brezhnev andropov and cernenko died in
the span of 28 months it was then that
the soviet union turned to a younger man
mikhail gorbachev struck up
relationships with western leaders
he signed a landmark agreement with u.s
president ronald reagan to ban an entire
class of nuclear missiles more than
it is our duty to move toward a
nuclear-free world a key advisor through
it all was yakovlev the former
ambassador to canada
at home gorbachev took first steps
towards democracy in the soviet union
u.s president reagan seized the moment
to break the soviet grip on eastern
europe mr gorbachev
tear down this wall
the berlin wall did come down setting
off a chain reaction that saw borders
open across eastern europe changes that
reshape the future of the continent
the cause of my life he said were the
reforms that we undertook in the soviet
union and in international politics it
propelled gorbachev to international
acclaim in 1990 canadians lined the
streets in ottawa to catch a glimpse of
the political superstar
that same year he won the nobel prize
for bringing the cold war to a peaceful
end but in the new russia the country's
economic woes only deepened for
reformers gorbachev did not bring enough
change for communist hardliners he
brought too much gorbachev would be
swept from power by the very reforms he
started what gorbachev tried to do is to
create a kind of
kindler gentler communist system but a
communist system nonetheless he tried to
reform the unreformable
and he fell apart on him gorbachev was
succeeded by boris yeltsin then vladimir
putin over time russia began to resemble
the old soviet union crimea was annexed
dissent was suppressed and this year
putin waged war on ukraine all but
burying perestroika and glasnost the
reforms and the openness that gorbachev
had ushered in
in later years gorbachev feared a return
to the cold war
still many european countries once
suppressed by the soviets owe gorbachev
a debt of gratitude for the independence
they now enjoy prime minister mulroney
who knew the russian leader in those
tumultuous years said gorbachev would be
remembered for his achievements
gorbachev he will be recognized in
history
as a truly great leader a great man
mikhail gorbachev was in power for only
six years but the changes he started
would alter the boundaries and the
politics of russia and its many
neighbors for decades to come
eric sorensen global news
tributes are pouring in for the former
soviet leader including from ursula van
der lion the head of the european
commission in a tweet she called
gorbachev a trusted and respected leader
saying he played a crucial role to end
the cold war and bring down the iron
curtain it opened the way for a free
europe this legacy is one we will not
forget
now to the worsening humanitarian
catastrophe in pakistan for a country
that produces less than one percent of
global greenhouse gas emissions it's
confronting the harsh reality of a
climate crisis that knows no borders
unrelenting rainfall has washed entire
villages off the map parts of southern
pakistan have been described as looking
like a small ocean pakistan's minister
of climate change calls it climate
dystopia at our doorstep as redmond
shannon reports this disaster highlights
the tensions on global climate response
as millions of people who lost
everything are in dire need of immediate
help
the scale of the flooding is hard to
comprehend affecting a third of
pakistan's land and around one in seven
people some 33 million more than a
thousand have lost their lives hundreds
of thousands of people have fled their
homes scrambling to save possessions
for god's sake help us says this man we
are sitting here out in the open on the
road one region has had almost nine
times the average rainfall for monsoon
season the pakistani government says the
bill for reconstruction is estimated to
be 13 billion dollars the scale of the
disaster is really mind-blowing you i
mean these are very preliminary
assessments and there are areas where
still nobody can actually access the
united nations has launched an aid
appeal for 210 million dollars the
pakistani people are facing a monsoon on
steroids the relentless impact of epical
levels of rain and flooding
the warming planet is a significant
factor higher temperatures are making
for heavier rainfalls across most of the
world and pakistan's thousands of
glaciers are more rapidly melting into
its rivers
the country is among the 10 most
susceptible nations to the effects of
climate change but its historic and
current carbon emissions per capita are
dwarfed by countries like canada at
climate change summits like cop26 richer
nations asked countries like pakistan to
cut emissions as they deal with a
climate that was caused by the developed
world and as wealthy nations again fell
short on a pledge to help fund their
transition away from fossil fuels we
have to think about you know the
immediate
concerns
but over the long haul
supports gonna be needed as in many
other places where we're seeing these
climate catastrophes unfold we
absolutely need a massive global
strategy
because these things are gonna keep
piling up and piling up the funding for
poorer nations will be a central theme
to the cop 27 summit in cairo this fall
redmond shannon global news london
and as redmond just mentioned this
year's monsoon season is compounded by
the increasingly rapid melting of
himalayan glaciers
there are more than 7 200 glaciers
within pakistan's borders that's the
highest concentration outside the north
and south poles now rising temperatures
are causing those glaciers to melt
faster and this year the runoff is
coming at the same time as this
particularly wet monsoon season
supercharged by the warming waters of
the bay of bengal
and in greenland some of the world's
largest ice sheets are rapidly melting
and new research shows the melt will
raise global sea levels more than twice
as much as previously thought here's
eric sorenson again to explain
time lapse video of a glacier in
greenland moving and calving new
icebergs into the sea a new study based
on warming that's already occurred
paints a dire picture that melting ice
from greenland alone will cause sea
levels to rise at least 27 centimeters
almost one foot over the next century
it's a steeper rise than other modeling
and the study concludes it's inevitable
this 27 centimeters is committed loss
based on today's climate unless we turn
back the clock on climate you know we're
on the hook for that there's no going
back nasa is measuring the disappearance
in greenland of ice mass that's normally
replaced
for thousands of years ice sheets would
melt and glaciers would slowly slide
into the sea but the ice was replenished
by snowfall maintaining a relative
balance now warmer water is one factor
melting ice shelves more quickly
speeding up the flow of ice into the
seas nasa estimates greenland has lost
279 billion tons of ice per year since
2002. it's hard to understate
just how
big and fast
the sea level changes over the next
century can be coastal regions around
the world will be most affected by
rising sea levels some research says the
vancouver area is vulnerable notably
richmond and delta which are just above
sea level the canadian climate institute
says overall this country must do more
that means building new sea walls and
hardening shorelines make sure that
no new infrastructure and no new
developments are built in areas that are
going to be underwater in the future
ottawa is expected to put forward a
climate adaptation strategy this fall
and coastal flooding will be part of
that that's going to cost us billions of
dollars and it's going to put lives at
risk unless governments take
much more aggressive policy action on
climate adaptation virtually all the
research concludes that sea levels are
certain to rise and canada with the
longest coastline in the world will have
to prepare
eric sorensen global news toronto
in the united states a state of
emergency has been declared in the
mississippi capital of jackson after
heavy rain and flooding caused the
city's main water treatment plant to
fail as emergency repairs commence
officials are scrambling to deliver
drinking water system in mississippi's
largest city failed leaving more than
150 thousand residents without safe
drinking water for an unknown period of
time until it is fixed it means we do
not have reliable running water at scale
with the national guard sent in
officials on tuesday called it a
massively complicated task of
distributing bottled water and restoring
service and water pressure to homes and
businesses forced to shut down
it means the city cannot produce
enough water
to fight fires
to reliably flush toilets and to meet
other critical needs
city officials say days of torrential
rain increasing the threat of flooding
in jackson affected its water treatment
options
the water is not safe to drink and i
would even say it's not safe to brush
your teeth with but jackson's system has
long been crippled by both inadequate
infrastructure and a lack of resources
to support it in 2021 winter storms
burst pipes and jackson residents were
without running water for an entire
month making up more than 80 percent of
the city's population black americans
are disproportionately affected despite
the infrastructure bill president biden
called a once in a generation chance to
rebuild essential systems across the
nation
never again can we allow what happened
in flint michigan and jackson
mississippi
can never let it happen again
some analysts say the city's high
percentage of low-income residents in
one of the poorest states in the country
is part of the reason why steady
predictable resources for public
services like drinking water still
aren't being made available despite that
presidential promise as part of the 1.2
trillion dollar infrastructure plan and
as for the problems at the plant in
jackson there's still no timeline on
when they'll be fixed nithu garcia
global news washington
prime minister justin trudeau is set to
make minor adjustments to his cabinet on
wednesday global news has learned
trudeau's mini shuffle tomorrow is being
triggered by two ministers who asked to
step aside from the cabinet to deal with
family health matters caucus sources say
this mini shuffle is not a response to
any political event or the performance
of the minister's withdrawing
the forceful response from russian
forces coming up moscow's deadly
retaliation to a ukrainian
counter-offensive
russian forces are responding to
ukraine's counter-offensive in the south
with a string of deadly attacks on
ukrainian cities a russian artillery
strike hit multiple buildings in
downtown harkev including apartment
towers leaving at least four people dead
and 11 wounded ukraine is claiming its
forces have broken through russian lines
at multiple points in the hassan region
and to have badly damaged a number of
strategically important bridges and
destroyed a number of russian ammunition
depots
a ship carrying ukrainian grain has now
docked in the drought-stricken horn of
africa the brave commander is the first
ship to have made the journey since the
russian invasion six months ago it's
carrying 23 000 tons of grain for the
united nations world food program that's
enough to feed 1.5 million people for a
month but it's estimated 82 million
people are at risk of starvation in
eastern africa due to drought conflict
and political instability
violence has subsided in baghdad after
two days of violent clashes left at
least 30 people dead in the iraqi
capital the relative calm began after
moktava al-sadr ordered his armed
supporters to withdraw from baghdad's
heavily fortified green zone loyalists
stormed key government buildings in the
area following news the influential
cleric was quitting after a political
deadlock prevented him from forming a
new government while ordering his
followers to stand down al-sadr also
apologized for the violence which left
more than 400 others hurt
where are canada's family doctors ahead
the systemic strain driving away these
medical professionals
a crisis continues to unfold in
emergency rooms across canada staffing
shortages unprecedented wait times and
full-out closures are being seen from
coast to coast to coast as part of our
series code blue global news recently
spent the day inside one emergency
department and found the er capacity
crunch is a symptom of a much larger
problem jeff semple explains
across the country hospital emergency
rooms are on life support
this toronto er is seeing more patients
arriving with advanced illness and they
often have something else in common
there is quite a
large number of patients who doesn't
have a family doctor how are you i'm
good thanks how are you millions of
canadians do not have access to a family
physician including the mcneils it's
been a challenge
their daughter was suffering stomach
pains the family spent hours in a
hospital emergency room for what turned
out to be a flu
it was the sort of thing we normally
wouldn't have taken a child to emergency
for it was appropriate for a family
doctor but we didn't have the chance
when they first moved to pei in 2018 the
wait list for a family doctor was four
years
but they were just told it will likely
be another four years
there's a lot of pressures on family
medicine right now the head of the
college of family physicians says the
problem is getting worse
family physicians
either
reducing their hours
going into other focused practices or
most concerning for me
medical students coming out and choosing
specialties other other than family
medicine the number of medical school
graduates choosing a career in family
medicine has been dropping for a decade
good morning one how are you
part of the reason for that reluctance
family doctors are required to run their
own business with a lot of overhead and
little support if you're trying to
navigate all of this complexity by
yourself without administrative support
without infrastructure without
additional team members it's not going
to work to that end dr ali damji adopted
a different model his office includes
nurses dietitians physiotherapists
social workers and admin staff the
so-called family health team model can
be found across the country but in small
numbers
dr damji believes it should play a
larger role to attract more medical
professionals to family medicine if
patients have access to comprehensive
primary care we see better health
outcomes better satisfaction lower
health care costs to the system
because patients without a family doctor
are much more likely to end up here
jeff semple global news toronto
the world health organization says it is
still possible to eliminate the monkey
pox outbreak in europe the who says case
counts are slowing in several european
countries including france germany and
portugal but to eliminate the disease
there needs to be an urgent boost in the
limited supply of vaccine
drinking danger next the new data on
just how much alcohol is too much for
your health
many people enjoy the odd cold beer on a
hot summer day but those drinks could be
more dangerous than you even think a new
report says alcohol is not good for your
health even in small amounts this is
according to the canadian center on
substance use and addiction drinking can
increase your risk of cancer heart
disease and stroke it also suggests
mandatory labeling of alcoholic
beverages to reflect safe portion sizes
but as karen lieberman explains it's
unclear if this will be enough for
people to rethink the way they drink
when it comes to alcohol consumption and
the question how much is too much the
message may be changing to me i know
that alcohol is uh usually like bad for
you but i didn't know like how bad it
was even in small quantities drinking
alcohol can have a big impact points out
the canadian center on substance use and
addiction with this new report we viewed
alcohol
consumption as harmful only if you have
dependents but we know that alcohol
consumption even
in the low amounts causes harm to the
entire body the ccsa's report found
having two drinks or fewer per week puts
an individual at low risk three to six
drinks per week poses a moderate risk
for developing certain cancers but
health risks become increasingly high
when someone has seven drinks or more
per week unlike almost any other risk
factor alcohol consumption affects the
whole body so we're talking about things
like infectious diseases but then we
also have neurological diseases so
alcohol impacts the brain we also have
cardiovascular diseases it affects the
heart there is also a strong link
between moderate to heavy drinking and
cancer this includes female breast as
well as head and neck so those kind of
your mouth your throat your larynx and
your esophageal as well as colorectal
and liver cancers doctors are calling
for mandatory alcohol warning labeling
like has long been the case with tobacco
and cannabis there is a huge lack of
understanding that a tall can of beer is
not one standard drink that sits one and
a half that a bottle of wine is actually
five standard drinks in canada a
standard drink has
13.45 grams of alcohol regardless of the
kind of drink you're having that kind of
thing does run in my family you know the
abuse of alcohol so
i think it's good that people are
talking about it more often and i
believe that giving people information
about what they're consuming
helps them to make more informed choices
so the next time you raise a glass it
might be something else karen lieberman
global news toronto
and that's global national for this
tuesday night i'm farah nasser on behalf
of our whole crew here i wanted to thank
you so much for spending part of your
evening with us
tonight's your canada is rayboro ontario
we love seeing your canada so please
email us those photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other good night
[Music]
you